today's show is sponsored by Jenny
éclairs electric chairs you'll have a
shocking time this is the technical
difficulties we are playing citation
needed I've got an almost randomly
selected article from everybody's
favorite reliable source of knowledge
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact they get right is a point and
a ding and there's a special prize for
particular good answers which is and
today we are talking about
stephania bhavini of course definitely
not the Wiltshire Fellini's broad guess
at which country were insulting today
yeah Italy all right sports person no
not at all interior designer actually
better from here silly but that's not
what she's playing that she's not fact
she's she's not famous for anything she
did chaps this is gone she's not famous
for interior design she had actually
drive an Italian of car no she um she
had an experiment on herself another
head don't think don't think medical
surgery two-headed you know that one
it's about 1989 medical science
definitely haven't gotten that far hmm
was she trying to work out what would
happen if you were the same pair of
jeans for three years
oh now you're wrong you're obviously
massively wrong but it is a kind of
AIT's a self-imposed thing that went on
for 130 day you lived in a hot-air
balloon
Oh lived somewhere yes under the same
balloon down where it's wetter down
where it's better under the sea not
quite yeah you're very close here on the
ground yes in a cave in fact for yr0
design purposes no an experiment about
circadian rhythms you got a point though
just an itch and some rock we're talking
absolute proper underground yeah Cavan
then rather than a cave my yellow up
tights go down kind of gay yes yes has
the women's world record for longest
cave isolation did
presented by Norris mcwhirter that
certificate what school right thank you
I'm reasonably sure I've heard or read
somewhere before
that in darkness the security and rhythm
of the humans about 23 hours apparently
it actually drifted towards first of all
28 hour day then a 48 hour one but
you're absolutely right have a point for
it beeing you know away from 24 hours
does that mean we do more in the dark is
that what you're saying way from any
reference away from the Sun come it's
currently setting over there away from
that our bodies generally go for twenty
five twenty six twenty I saw surprised
that I have business hasn't set up
underground just to get longer days out
of people I think that's basically the
Amazon warehouse is that does that
proportions that mean you might get I
don't know a three hour dinner break
actually go for hours it'd be double
wouldn't it yeah well no I wouldn't you
just work 24 more hours I can't see them
adding an extra no but you did a break
it have to be longer wouldn't it i
depends you're coming you're the union
man here I am the union man thank you
very much the Union honey comes over oh
we can play no he can't he's on strikes
obviously she was down in the cave with
no external lights no clocks no anything
like wait a minute she's an interior
designer yes she's going to have clocks
and cushions and tables and rows what do
you think she did take down with her
Shea's long well it's it's really big
floppy cops just roaming here has her
only companions no idea anything that
would will kind of keep her spirits up
during I saw the cat's paint white
despair there's an island dis this is a
faster period drink two minutes um not
quite word you say cat see it's not
quite right in fact you wouldn't want
them down moles and you on the wrong way
down the cartoon food chain uh uh hook
and mice mice thank you points to
friendly mice named at Giuseppe and
Nicoletta we are in Italy naturally no
we're not you know take guess where it
was with France Austria Switzerland
wrong continent America they got their
own in caves in Europe this was partly
organized by NASA
America I'm not white I did not succumb
to an interior designer and say do you
want to live in a cave I mean wherever
Flay look they wanted to use the cave
later on they needed somebody to fit it
out and they wanted it done could you
just acquire it I mean you know Ray's
not quoted you cheese off I think we
need some of the walls painting
definitely she actually decorated the
cave with cutouts mate and cardboard of
people tell me it was okay it doesn't
say like a Bill Clinton bit from Bugsy
Malone where's he got one bolt eat or a
little rat miniature railroad Bugsy
Malone as well yeah when fat Sam's gangs
all been killed they set off follow a
cardboard cutout
maybe the Train things home alone yeah
what else he should take down with them
skateboard not really all that goodness
on the cave floor oh yeah 15 pounds of
LSD substances food yeah okay yes there
was food on butter's companion is
actually not that different from to
expect someone in 2014 deploy so Morgan
Freeman no the only way she could
communicate was through one of these
Morgan Freeman a bat just a computer
sign one example where in in when 1989
sex terminal that talked to the folks at
NASA bear in mind yo NASA's back a
missile so she's getting light then from
discrete I know didn't say without
lights without natural light yeah oh so
he was in the dark no no she just got no
outside datum to tell her when each day
and night but she's in control of that
Oh which is so she can know when she's
can exist as she normally would but that
then set this down eight hours this is
where the perseverance that you'd need
to do only things wouldn't pay off for
me I just keep a clock going and let's
turn the lights off at the right time
well as things she wasn't allowed them
the computer wouldn't have had a clock
it would just be a terminal back and
forth to tell right at least on April
the first have taken the opportunity
it's a really thorough
computer terminal if she can seen the
outside world I want to just type the
word help repeatedly with they have done
it oh god they have done it repeatedly
oh no no I'm yeah that would be a bit
harsh yeah yeah I won't say who they
were and what they do st later now all
they done is block the toilet in the gym
the gents first-floor loo she lost a lot
of weight while she's in there because
obviously her rhythms have spread out so
she's taking meals less often she lost
weight um she actually came out on may
the 22nd 1989 is the next question to me
what Dave did she think it was yeah I
thought you have a point for Jess she
went in on January 13th came out made
the 22nd and she thought it was you know
I like that yeah I would have pretended
what he's claiming is biscuit right now
get in there I'm I'm this is my the room
by the way do you want to guess what it
was you know size is what it was made
off because they actually put built a
room down in the cave I'm rum rewinded
from my admiration I thought she was in
a pitch-black dark cave drippings
yeah awesome suddenly the bill or a
Bijou residence it's hardly a Bijou
residence 10th chipboard it's a twenty
by twelve foot acrylic glass room glass
acrylic glass yeah okay so she can still
see out to the eighth but she's
constricted in movement yeah whoo yeah
is that the kind of thing they only give
them when they go to Mars that I think
was one of the reasons yeah it was an
experiment on circadian rhythms on how
you can survive with no external trance
in a box that you can see out of just a
black which is oh my god that's horribly
no now I see the bubble idea I don't
even report a cabin awesome Stefano
Fellini has the women's world record
there is a men's world record for
complete isolation which is again was it
the Russians in that thing that's
happened recently that it was 300 days
that wasn't underground chamber
isolation I'm a there was still kind of
locked in a room not making Joel I'm
gonna say so not the Chilean miners I
know it's an italian sociologist and
caver called Mauricio Mont Albini
who just wanted a really long holiday
doing his hobby
Oh study yeah can I get this paid for
fair the interior designers cave wasn't
a natural environment like sociologists
in caver
how can I get this comped that's
actually an entire year he entered on
December the 6th of 1992 got out
December the 5th of 1990 was the proper
record he was right he broke all records
I think it was June 6th so he'd again
had about half that Weaver had about
double the time wow that's a lot more
than spinning out to a 28 hour
yefim isn't it yeah well they said with
her as well it became a faucet I'm just
quoting what it says here I'm not sure
what this means
his immune defense system fell from a
level of 23200 there's not a lot living
down there so it's not fighting stuff
off all the time yeah what are the unity
there are no units given in this at all
this is basically a multi resistances
all we know is it whatever it is if
something drops to zero that's bad so
above the cave for first offending
fellini there was a trailer for what
film just on a limp endlessly she went
insane um when they announced the end of
the experiment to her went what you know
they sent a letter saying okay you can
come out what do you think she sent back
missus this may be a translation for
meeting or it may be the original goth
question I've just got the place look in
our one to one point it was actually are
you really serious but you're absolutely
right it's a question mark and disbelief
so I'm giving it away for that one I
also like the the newspaper article I'm
now loving the original here it
references what happened to her
immediately after she came out what were
they what the scientists doing to her
ruling point poking yep who said poking
first one of those I'm gonna give you
both points hey poked with needles and
tagged with electrodes and then given
some vouchers and told to enjoy yourself
here's one Freeman oh no your immune
systems dropped what surprised me here
is now I'm
this up I was made a connection he
exists there's the other from the Daily
News in 1989 experiment coordinator
Moritz young man tell beanie oh I put my
tinfoil hat on for that one thank you
very much the guy who later went on to
break the record again was the
experiment coordination where Zuma Lee
because he is the world's expert on
staying in a constant or even learnt all
he needed to know and then used it
against doing it first
well she's down that all the time he's
just sat there rubbing his hands going
soon well I just like the idea that you
know you just went you've got right I
have to do this experiment prior to mine
what profession to choose who will be
hardiest against these hardships in
Syria you're actually with the hold kind
of rubbing hands um miss Fellini it's
has heard a human voice other than her
own for the first time
Stefania I am your God talking to you
even back when what do I say
I know this is your God talking to you I
like the idea they hired James Mason
just to make sure it sounded right it's
the the last thing then um is a quote
from a news article about this um she
dismisses concerned that her
contribution to science was an ordeal
what what did she say it was instead
really time to think cheap holiday you
know I'm gonna Gary the point on that it
was a very simple thing questions are
good they seem she was allowed books yes
yeah well the books in under guitar oh I
knew there'd be a guitar that's a fair
point that you are going to Mars what is
like 563 or something you get it on
there you just there's gonna be that one
dick Cole just plain smoke on the war
over honesty 20 quid a conspiracy
hey guys I brought this along
come by our firm there was an eternity
when I was a fresher that someone
directly above me in the room but was
playing smoke on the water and just
trying to learn
I don't after about five minutes of this
house door slams stomp stomp stomp stomp
stomp stomp
door opens pulls the plug up mmm
door slams stop not a word even though
someone gets on this and in the space
capsule to get out or hole holes in an
accordion or some harmonica it's one of
the sunsets just hey Leggett I love the
idea that she's not down there with some
acoustic segment she got like 200 watt
Gibson XG Mira ha if you just rock it
out in this cave to be fed there are
astronauts on the ISS I mean Chris
Hadfield was one who took their guitar
up Windham on space musician facts
though Neil Armstrong took a theremin to
the moon didn't he yeah yeah I think you
took a theremin with it screw this guy's
it's not gonna sound Spacey on off
without it
yeah but the way player me can you
imagine you're in like I don't know the
capsule and he lives there that's not
strictly true but I can tell you that we
have a last layer called music out of
the moon a cassette tape that was taken
I near Armstrong to the moon barren and
he played it back to them oh thanks Neil
brilliant just that blow when you're
trying to drive you know really
concentrate someone puts that frigging
CD on that's in with this theremin music
in it brought this for his moon landing
moment all right at the end of the show
congratulations Gary
I'm trying to destroy this one but he's
not wearing a parka so he just gonna put
it over his head that's what we play the
game for you you win a trip to the edge
of the atmosphere with the host of 90s
gameshow small talk oh really
it's Irv Ronnie Corbett low Earth orbit
so you enjoy that in the meantime that's
been my gray that's been Gary Brannen
that's been Chris Joel Arvin Tom Scott
we'll see you next time thanks for
watching
tell us if you liked it or even better
tell someone else and if you want more
there are all new episodes of our
reverse trivia podcast at tecnico dot
uk'
you